have a new video tonight showing a man
caught on camera exposing himself at a
valley park the image is being shared on
social media by a concerned citizen who
is hoping this person is identified fast
christian casarez joining us live in
studio now with those details well brian
and denise megan mejia captured this
video on her cell phone while she and
her mother were recently visiting
gilchrist park up in the northwest she
has notified authorities but is asking
everyone to pay extra close attention to
help identify the person
oh my god and then i kind of looked at
him again and he was just exposing
himself a shocking surprise for megan
mejia and her family after a quick trip
to their neighborhood park in the
northwest took a twist when this man was
caught exposing himself bro this dude is
legit at the park mejia says her 26
second explicit video clip was shot
around six o'clock on january 17 at
gilchrist park near hualapai and grand
teton the unidentified man seemed to be
unbothered others were nearby we start
speaking loudly for them to hear us
saying there's a man here who's doing
this you guys need to go home
he heard the man that was exposing
himself hurt us looked at us and he
freaked out pulled his pants back up and
ran the incident quickly shared on
social media apps like next door
alerting neighbors to be on their guard
since the area is very popular with
children it's shocking honestly
because we come to this park because it
feels safe for our kids and so to hear
that honestly it really surprised me
very quiet neighborhood actually this
whole area is pretty quiet we don't have
a lot of i don't think we have a lot of
activity up here mejia who is also a
teacher says her love for children
forced her to speak up and hopes this
man can get the medical attention he
needs he didn't seem all there in my
head i'm thinking either he had a mental
illness or he was under the influence of
something just because he was just kind
of out of it
well mejia has contacted authorities
about this incident she tells me she
added her in her initial response
prompted her to call 3-1-1 metro police
telling us
911 your best option christian gossett
is live local now